schon in vier jahren sollen tief im
weltall zwei sterne verschmelzen und uns
eine waschechte nova bieten ein
blutroter fleck im sternbild schwan wird
erwartet so hell wie der polarstern
sichtbar nicht nur mit riesigen
teleskopen sondern mit dem bloßen auge
davon geht zumindest ein us
astronomenteam aus wie wahrscheinlich
solch eine vorhergesagte
sternenexplosion tatsächlich ist und
alle weiteren weg zu diesem thema
bekommt ihr jetzt herzlich willkommen
bei pixum science fiction
gestern lag ich noch bei mir auf dem
hausdach hier in berlin und beobachtet
die die sterne total beeindruckend war
dass man trotz der lichtverschmutzung
hier in der großstadt noch einige sehen
kann zum beispiel den jupiter und wenn
man genau hinguckt sieht man auch dass
er wirklich größer als die sterne ist
und eine kleine fläche hat hammer kommen
wir zum thema natürlich mal wieder über
whatsapp vorgeschlagen vielen dank
genauer gesagt geht es um zwei sonnen
die im 1842 lichtjahre entfernten stern
system kec 98 32 27 kollidieren sollen
das ergebnis eine sogenannte rote nova
diese these hat ein amerikanisches
forschungsteam auf der jahrestagung der
american astronomical society im letzten
jahr verkündet wenn sie recht behalten
und wie diese sternexplosion tatsächlich
mit bloßem auge beobachten können wäre
es tatsächlich zum ersten mal in der
geschichte der menschheit der fall dass
dies mit ansage passiert die us
astronomen und astronomen haben hinweise
darauf gefunden dass der doppel stern im
sternbild schwan kurz vor einer
explosion steht konkret besteht aus zwei
sternen die sich umkreisen schon jetzt
sind sie sich so nah dass sich ihre
äußeren hüllen berühren dazu einer der
beteiligten forscher larry molnar
die beiden sterne teilen eine einzige
atmosphäre wie zwei erdnüsse in einer
gemeinsamen schade forschungs 7 weltweit
sind an der sache dran und messung
nahmen bereits erste ergebnis offenbart
elf stunden brauchen die beiden sterne
für eine umkreisung doch die umlaufbahn
des pärchens hat sich in den letzten
jahren verändert der lichtschwächere
stern der beiden benötigt eine deutlich
kürzere zeit um an dem zweiten stern
vorbeizuziehen
und er nimmt an fahrt auf viele
untersuchungen wurden durchgeführt um
auszuschließen dass das verhalten des
doppelsterns nicht auf einen dritten
stern zurückzuführen ist ja und bislang
sprechen alle hinweise dafür dass es
sich um zwei sterne halt die eben kurz
vor ihrer verschmelzung stehen und nicht
unter dem schwerkraft einfluss eines
anderes anderen sterns stehen das alles
erinnert an den doppelstern v13 und 90
der 2008 explodierte
nachdem sich seine beiden sterne immer
näher gekommen waren fest steht dennoch
das 2 sterne miteinander kollidieren das
passiert sehr selten es gibt schätzungen
nach denen von den 100 milliarden sterne
in der milchstraße kaum einer
eine kollision hinter sich hat sie im
vorfeld aber sogar noch vorher zu
bestimmen das erinnert schon fast sechs
richtigen im lotto bisher ist e10 98 32
27 übrigens nur mit starken teleskopen
zu sehen falls es aber wirklich zu einer
roten nova kommen sollte wird sie wohl
so hell strahlen wie der nordstadt bzw
die sehr hellen sterne des großen wagens
und das forschungsteam kann es selbst
kaum fassen dazu mit war laut das wäre
ein bedeutendes ereignis nicht nur für
die wissenschaft sondern auch weil es
die menschen auf der straße faszinieren
kann wenn die vorhersage stimmt dann
wäre dies das erste mal in der
geschichte dass eltern auf eine dunkle
stelle am himmel zeigen können und sagen
seht kinder dort versteckt sich ein
stern der bald ganz hell aufleuchten
wird hammer wir werden darüber berichten
vielleicht sogar live wenn ihr kein
video dazu und auch zu allen anderen dem
verpassen wollt die youtube aber box die
funktioniert ja einfach gar nicht dann
hättet mich bei whatsapp nur dann
verpasst der kein video über whatsapp
erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen
anderen vom neuesten video täglich
garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und
am besten auch mein schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür ihr klicken aber nicht immer
die glocke vergessen und hier geht es
weiter mit dafür auch drauf klicken
da geht es um eine sensationelle
supernova und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran